[Music starts]
[Audio Description - not captioned in this video]
[Drayana Dunson] I've been through
18 foster homes, five group homes,
and five shelters - five different
shelters - in the past 13 years.
[Amyia Berry] My parents had recently
had got a divorce. I would have like
bad thoughts and would end up actually
here in Cincinnati Children's a lot.
So, that's when they decided that it would be
better for me to go to the foster care system.
[Judith W Dexheimer, PhD] So, there are
about 470,000 children in foster care
across the United States. And of kids in
foster care, they have disjointed medical care.
And when they change placements,
or change to a new foster family,
they frequently change and potentially
lose their medical records.
[Dunson] When your caseworkers drop you off, they
don't give them the information that they need.
They just let them know "hey,
got this child, she's a female,
she's this age, and we'll be bringing
her in. Do you have any beds open?"
[Dexheimer] So, I applied for an NLM grant ...
... because what the NLM is trying
to do, with health disparities
and health disparities research, fits directly
into what we want to do with our care.
Our goal was to start with
the kids who were 18 and over,
who are eligible for, or emancipating out of care,
and help provide them with both their medical
records, and a portion of their data from
job and family services - so from the
people who have their actual custody.
So, they could see their records. They could see
their major diagnoses, their current medications,
their immunizations. And then then they
could become stewards of their own data,
but then they also had it in
a form that they could take
with them as they transition
from pediatric to adult care.
[Dunson] One of the reasons I use Health Hero
was to set up my appointment for my pregnancy.
I did not remember all
my testing that I had done
cause I never had like actual
copy of my insurance card.
So, my insurance card was on there and they
can scan it and put it through their system.
If you don't know your information by heart, it
will be there for you to remember and it just like
- it helps. It shows you more information that
you can learn outside of what people tells you.
[Dexheimer] One of the great things
about doing the funding through the
National Library of Medicine
is the primary focus was how
to build an application with the
end users involved in a novel way.
How to get it out to them so that they
could put it in their hands again and
then how to evaluate whether or not they used it.
[Berry] A feature on Health Hero, that was
helpful to me, was under immunization records.
I was able to login, look at my records, and
print it out to get into nursing school.
I grew up in the hospital and
that made me want to become
a nurse because I would become very
close to the nurse. I would just like
to take care of people for the rest
of my life if I ever get the chance.
[Dunson] It's important for youth that's
being emancipated to have Health Hero
because of the fact that it's just
something that you need to know.
It's - you're not going to always have someone
there that remembers all your information.
My advice, to a person that was
going through what I went through,
is you never give up. You don't let the foster
care make you who you are. You always fight and
you don't give up. You don't let the foster
care define you. You don't let it break you.
[Music and audio description]
[Music fades to silence]